what's up guys back today with another
longer video which is to build a job
board app that could actually be a real
startup that people use there's a lot of
different places to find entry-level or
junior developer jobs on the internet
for example github jobs Stack Overflow
jobs you have angel list you have indeed
but filtering through those especially
because you kind of have to spam
applications for your first job can take
a long time so the good thing about all
these job boards is they have public
api's for the most part you will always
want to start with an MVP that is the
Minimum Viable Product today that means
we're gonna start with a single data
feed that is a single job board API
feeding into our app and then finally
we're gonna have a super minimal simple
front we're gonna do this in react and
material UI on the front end we're gonna
use an Express server Redis for our data
storage because we're not writing or
persisting any data that is not part of
the job feed and then finally a node
cron job to fetch these jobs and refresh
them at a certain interval which are
gonna be filtered through an algorithm
so let's draw this all out to get a
better idea of our plan here's our front
end what we basically want here is a
list of jobs this is going to be pulling
data from our API and that'll be
expressed and then this will pull from
our store which is actually gonna be
Redis and Redis will be populated by our
cron call it a worker which is pulling
from one or more API is it's going to be
eventually multiple is gonna be a job
board API so like let's say indeed we
have github we have stack jobs and this
is going to be filtered through our
algorithm
we're filtering down the jobs getting
rid of the senior jobs getting rid of
the manager jobs and eventually when we
make a more complicated we could even
look through the description for years
of experience and create search indexes
and different things like that but again
the minimum is just going to be pulling
the jobs in and filtering them down ok
so this is our plan let's start with the
front end I know a lot of you guys like
react and it's gonna actually be super
simple let's just do a create react app
to get started I already have a folder
our directory here called junior dev so
let's do a v8 react app and then call it
client you guys know that I love
material UI so let's install that as
well once we get into our client and
let's do a Arn ad
okay that's done and we will start our
react okay let's go through these stuff
we can actually delete note s you always
want to write s in real life but not
today
leave logo and also clear this out here
now it's open the material UI Docs let's
get our component API and let's get a
title for our page typography h1 let's
just copy this instead of putting it
directly in app let's make a new
component for jobs and then let's make a
new component for a single job all job
which we'll use in jobs and then let's
import the act
it's for its default function
in this we will auger fee okay so just
to explain what I'm doing here I am
making a separate component because I
want our app just to hold our state and
then jobs will actually hold our
component tree our render styling and
app will hold our application State our
use state and call our hooks or Kubota
did mount and for state I was really
confusing sorry we're using typography
here and let's variant typography
variant
naming our page entry-level software
jobs I think it's a good name and save
import jobs throw that in there like
this
okay that is some huge text but we're
gonna leave it for now within jobs we
already know we're gonna import job make
this a similar export we'll just copy
this whole thing almost sneezed
okay turn div and then this will just be
a single job row which will put on a
class name of single job and then we'll
just do this in advance because we know
we're gonna eventually have to write
some CSS to style this stuff let's make
a job list you should probably actually
be matching our component name just to
change that back jobs and then job okay
so
let's just say that we're passing down
some props for all our jobs from our app
which is holding our state let's just do
it like this and let's do some mock JSON
that we might return from our API that's
w/e software engineer one and company
Google there's gonna be a bunch of
fields but let's just leave them like
that for now I'm a mock job so we don't
get mixed up mock just being mock JSON
data and I should work and we could do
jobs map this will return a job job
equals job hopefully that's not too
confusing okay now just here do you
stretch your job in the Box put a job
title let's see if this works it is job
a cup title and job company and let's
actually add some CSS or job and just
make it a display flex
oh that's right always freaking hard
switching from JSX the JavaScript okay
there we go boom I'll leave it like that
for now we can add more stuff to this
this list if we want this Facebook Apple
it'll map it out for us let's give that
a little bit of margin a little bit of
padding let's do it 10 pixels top left
right 0 and then padding will be the
same not too bad
that's about it so our front end we
could cut we call this like kind of done
let's call this done for now and let's
return to it after doing some full stack
stuff so I'm gonna collapse our client
let's see what our actual data feed is
gonna look like coming from our source
which I'm just gonna use as github jobs
because I know that has a really good
clean API output that you don't need a
key for or anything so API github jobs
open it up you can see some examples
here ok so it says the API supports
pagination over turn 50 at a time and
you can do it by adding a parameter to
your queries before jumping ahead we
just know we want these JSON
representation of these jobs that we can
manipulate it with our node worker so
what I'm actually gonna do is call a
similar URL like this in our node side
which is gonna give us output like this
just by eyeballing this I could see that
it is somewhat matching what we already
wrote out here in app KS where there's a
title somewhere
yes like that senior full-stack nodejs
developer and there is a company
somewhere and we can also tell in
advance that location is going to be an
important field too but basing our
analysis on this we could start to model
kind of what our workers gonna do as
well as how we want our API to act as
well so all right looking back at our
plan let's actually just make a folder
for all our boxes here so this is the
client right API is gonna be simple
Express server and then the worker is
going to have our algorithm and it's
gonna be calling our api's on a cron job
which is add a set interval so maybe
every hour in the day we want to refresh
these api's refresh or Redis and make
sure that everything is up-to-date
there's no expired jobs the companies
don't want people to see anymore and
we're basically staying in sync with
whatever is in our upstream data source
so within worker I want to create an
index GS which is gonna manage all our
worker tasks and I know already that
we're gonna need the cron node library
it's just gonna help us run simple cron
jobs which is what I was saying before
is the it's the way you run a task on an
interval basically forever if you want
to opening up a new terminal tab going
out to our main directory and within our
main directory I'm just gonna create a
package.json which is going to be
accessible from all our different
folders see that was created here and
then we just want to install cron as a
dependency now inside a worker I just
this is the way I pretty much start with
every every app you just copy kind of
the basic usage and you build your way
out from there so all this does is it's
running a node process where we're
importing the library and then this is
called a run shorthand cron syntax
something like that
cron guru you can see it here okay so
this site is really useful no not this
site
cron Guru crontab guru okay so these
asterisks are called a cron schedule
expression and it's basically symbols
for how often you want your job to run
you could test it over here slash one
that's actually every minute this is
every second this is every second minute
it's every third minute right so you
just have to play around with the syntax
it'll tell you here how to do it and
then you could do kind of whatever your
interval you want so you could do like
once a day I think one yeah so you got
it you just got to mess with it to do
what you want and then you could just
Google exactly what you want to do and
you hold a cron expression for that but
this is kind of a playground to get the
chronic
and you you definitely want to do all
right so let's test this um this basic
implementation of cron to just see if it
works and in our real production app
this is actually gonna run every second
not every second every let's say hour to
fetch our jobs so this will fire off
some function which is now being passed
in as this anonymous function that is
just console logging but what we're
gonna put in there is our script to
fetch the jobs and then filter them down
so in this worker folder I'm gonna make
a github or rather let's do it this way
let me get tasks folder and then we'll
do one called fetch github j/s and we
just want to play around with that
you know github API and get it to do
what we want so the good part about the
github API the good thing about the
github API and part of the reason why I
picked it is because it is pretty much
all developer jobs so we don't have to
filter out for developer jobs we could
just assume they're all tech jobs and
then we will take the ones that are just
junior software engineer or more
specifically not senior or not manager
so we know our URL is roughly gonna look
like this to do a back-end URL fetch
request I'm gonna install the node fetch
library which is the same as the
client-side fetch library but you could
use it in nodejs
it's or just require like that then
let's do an anonymous acing function
just to actually now let's do it this
way
explore defaults async function just did
a hey Siri for something nope okay so
fetch github there I'll just call it
here just for testing purposes and
within here let's do a jobs await H s
URL equals this without the query string
let's break this down a little bit we
have a question mark then a description
equals and Ruby and page equals one so
this is called a query string here it's
a way to pass parameters through a URL
so so we're passing parameters to the
server through the query string syntax
which is key equals value like this so
in our case we're gonna want to iterate
through the pages that as we want to get
all the results from all the pages and
combine them together the way I think we
want to do that is just by leaving this
like this so this is just our truly base
URL and then let's actually see what
happens let's see how many jobs we get
back just by doing this and then logging
out jobs length keep in mind that this
function is gonna run because we're
calling it here when we just run a node
on fetch github KS
hey I forgot we still can't do that yes
okay undefined
let's console like this jobs oh forgot
we also have to do this this is just our
raw response
this is jobs as that JSON still not
resolving because this is an async
function - okay 50 I already kind of
knew this going in but if you put no
parameters here it just gives you the
first page only so we have to add a
query string for each page and iterate
through to get all the results until we
get back an empty page best way to solve
this is to keep adding one to the page
number so we start at zero then we try
page 1 then retry page 2 until we get
back page with zero results so if this
is the way we do it for one page we're
just gonna want to run this same
subroutine for every page that's not
empty to make this a little more clear I
don't like really how we've written this
out so far let's just do it like this
maybe it's just me being lazy so while
the page result count is not empty we're
gonna do this and we have to keep track
of the page we're on as well as the
result counts so let's make a result
counts or not zero value because if it's
zero it'll break our loop so let's just
start it at an arbitrary value 1 and
then after we fetch the first page it'll
be 50 then it'll be whatever the second
page is until it's zero at which point
this while loop will break so we'll
initialize it to 1 and then let's also
initialize our what are we gonna call it
on page equals zero let's start on page
zero okay so this URL will do a template
literal here and then slash or not a set
of slash we'll do our query string H
equals on page okay so we loop to get
our jobs we get our jobs length we're
gonna want to also push the jobs we get
back into an array called all jobs let's
do all jobs push the jobs we get back
from the page let's keep this in here
just so we know what's happening and
then finally increase our on page value
okay
again just three of you setting our
result count to a non-zero value
starting on page zero creating an empty
array to hold the results were getting
back from the API we start a while loop
that's going to run as long as we're
getting results back by increasing one
page at a time so getting paid zero
getting page one getting page two
here's where the URL is constructed base
URL from up here and then page starting
at zero pulling out the JSON from the
response putting that JSON in our array
logging out how many jobs we got back
increased in the page count repeating
until we run out of or rather we run
into an empty page finally we have all
our jobs so let's just log out how many
jobs we got total which we're gonna
eventually be returning all right now
these console logs give us an idea of
what's happening in our function here
otherwise we would have no idea since we
refactored a little bit we have to call
the function again let's see what
happens
hopefully this is not infinite loop
please oh oh oh no okay okay what
happened there I guess we didn't break
oh because we're not sitting result
count okay so you got to do this results
count equals length okay there that
should work now but for the most part
good
okay okay so there's one thing we also
overlooked I think let's look back at
this this is a sample response we're
getting back and if we look at this
whole object let's just assume this is
like page zero it's coming back with an
array but then we're pushing that array
directly into our all jobs so this is
actually creating a array of arrays
whereas really we want a flat array just
the single array holding all these job
objects so that simple way to do that is
to spread that in with a spread operator
we're just dumping the array into
another array by spreading the values in
if we run that we're totally gonna see
this is gonna work super confident why I
didn't not work that time that's weird
interesting okay that's probably
something we have to debug maybe as a
weird response from the server
so our fetch github function is done
we're returning all our jobs now I think
we actually want a way to save these
jobs into a local storage that we can
retrieve through our API and actually
before we do that I'm getting ahead of
myself
but we want to call this entire function
on an interval so let's go back to
crontab let's just call it every I know
let's yeah let's let's let's call it
every minute make sure I'm doing that
right yeah every minute every minute
here we'll import our fetch github
function that's github boom just throw
it in here oh and the beauty of this is
we can repeat this for as many functions
as we want right we could we could fetch
github we could fetch Stack Overflow
jobs we could fetch indeed and we could
create a cron tap for each one that is
not dependent on one another to succeed
or fail so these can be all trying in
parallel and they could also give us
kind of a rolling refresh of our job so
maybe one can run every tenth minute of
the hour one can run every 20th minute
and it'll just continuously refresh
without hitting any one of these api's
too often let's test the the cron aspect
of that I just turned it on and it's
running for the first time now well then
it should run again after a minute yeah
and that's not gonna work because I
actually I ran directly to fetch skip
github one but if I do index okay it's
gonna wait a minute
oh [ __ ] okay I messed up I messed up
okay so I've copied exactly over from
crontab every minute okay well I guess
we you put six stars no do seconds and
if you put five and I'll do minutes so
lesson learn there so we'll see if that
works after a minute and in the meantime
let's say let's talk about storage and
like I mentioned earlier we're gonna
want to store these jobs actually in
Redis now I already have Redis installed
but you can install it through homebrew
pretty easily just if you don't have
homebrew installed you look up homebrew
installation you just it's a simple easy
download and then you can install
anything with a brew install for example
Redis and then it'll basically install
Redis under the hood in your system in a
directory called the brew services so
then you can start and stop restart it
from from that position jumping back up
to this you'll notice that it worked
after a minute so that's awesome so
let's see if it runs again after another
minute I just cleared the terminal there
with command K but like I was thinking
about Redis I already installed it with
brew install Redis and you can install
it yourself if you don't already have it
there are a couple different ways to
install Redis but it should always
connect the same way since I'm starting
a new project here I just want to make
sure my Redis is clear so oops there's a
command line command that allows you to
connect to the Redis client and then we
want to clear all our our Redis with a
it's a similar language to like a sequel
where you can basically this is like a
drop table and we just cleared
everything out of our Redis we got a
fresh start you'll see you ran again
after a minute so let's just we can stop
that we could leave it running whatever
I'm just gonna stop it but we know our
crontab refresh is working every minute
with our fetch github
okay I have Redis installed and if
you're not familiar with Redis it's just
a key value store so it's an in-memory
database my sequel is a little bit
different because it's on disk but Redis
is just memory so it's not persistent
and that means if your system shuts off
you lose all your RAM so it's not a
fault-tolerant database it's not a
durable database and the upside is
though that it's really fast it's kind
of like an object in JavaScript you just
if you have the key it's constant time
access you just pull it out of your
Redis store and then you could serve it
up in our case jumping back over to
these these job JSON that we got from
github you can see every job has a UUID
which is a guaranteed unique ID because
it has so many characters and it's
random characters so they'll be
guaranteed unique every time every job
has one of these IDs so that's a natural
candidate to use as a Redis key I'm
thinking within Redis our key is going
to be this ID and our value is just
going to be the whole job object so it
would be a string version of this then
we can then pull out we know it's
already JSON so we can just string a PHY
it and then when we pull it out we'll
just parse it into a JavaScript object
now this is the lightly tricky part of
this is okay how do we access Redis
through our node worker right because we
have all the jobs here and now we're
just logging them and throwing them away
but we want to put them in Redis and I
answered that as there's a node client
library to access and connect to and do
all the Redis actions so it's an
interface that node uses called the
client that's a library that will do
everything you need to do in Redis and
you can do it through node with this
library
so I'm just going to search from node
Redis and then we will install it just
like the same way as before and I'm
gonna do exactly like I said before what
the getting started dock to say I know
this is gonna be better if we promise if
I this library because you can see right
now that we have all the Redis commands
here like set is setting a key and then
there's one called get which will
retrieve that key just think of it like
an object so if you put in key a and
then the val is one then you do client i
get you'll retrieve that one from the a
key set and get functions are async so
it's not gonna be in line with your
javascript code and that's just the name
of the game because Redis is not in
JavaScript so there's no way to know
when it's response comes back
programmatically in line it's it's gonna
wait Redis could be over a network so
it's gonna take an indeterminate amount
of time to serve the request and then
that's gonna come back to the function
call in this format so this is the
standard callback format and node error
and then data replies is going to be the
response now you can just ignore all of
that because we're gonna promise if I
this library with the promise if I you
tell in node which will convert callback
functions into promises that we could
use a weight or then promise chaining
with and so on let me just do this I'm
just literally copy pasting it from the
docks and get it a sick is the example
which is converting that client that get
function to a promise I'm gonna put this
below the client variable declaration so
it works and I can tell you now that
we're also going to need a set a sync we
were thinking of setting each job as its
own item in Redis right which would be
fine if we were
ever querying for those keys but we're
not were in the MVP gonna just get all
the jobs serving back to the client and
then we'll let the client handle
pagination or any kind of showing and
hiding of these jobs so until we do that
or rather until we decide we want to
optimize this query on the server we
could actually just set the response
from github as the value of a single key
it'll be a huge text blob and we just
serve up to the front-end and the only
reason we're doing this is because of
performance we don't want to have to
wait for the API to respond every time
we serve a client request so Redis is
only a buffer that's an intermediary
holding this data that we're only
fetching once every hour because the
jobs are refreshing that often so that's
a long-winded way of saying that once we
create these this all jobs array we
actually are just gonna throw the whole
thing under one key and we'll call that
key github
also let's let's hold out of this hold
on to this um get folks into our head
because we're gonna we're not gonna be
pulling out of our Redis until we're in
the API layer which is serving the jobs
request man I've kind of a stuffy nose
okay let's do the set async and this
takes a value github or a key rather
github and then a value will be are all
jobs we might need to stringify that but
we'll test it out
okay
it's friend node worker tasks let's get
up and see if that works we could test
it like this get you'd hope that we
still have a read a CLI open there okay
so far
nothing happened that's not a good sign
here's why call our function just as a
test you know take that out okay okay
hope this sniffily nose hasn't been
annoying you guys too much it's actually
annoying me and I hope it's not super
loud on the microphone we get command
today's argument of type object hey I
didn't like that at all
um I'm not I'm not using get so I don't
know what it's talking about here but um
okay I know now set and then okay let's
try that okay set give Dave's argument
of type object and as we expected this
is like an array think this is gonna
work be honest
nice okay github that is Redis is
working our fetch worker is is totally
great we'll leave these logs in just so
we have that telemetry that
observability but everything is working
oops okay just make sure that's still
working with our crontab here oops we're
supposed to remind me to take that out
leave that running and we'll jump over
to our next piece if we look at our plan
API so let's just review this Oh
actually so we've got this API part done
still need this still me of this and
then we'll improve our front-end last
it's a filter algorithm alright let's
look at what's in our store here so
we're getting jobs back and like I said
we we want to start with a really simple
algorithm that is just filtering out by
position so just taking like eyeballing
this I can see that in the title we can
gain a few insights into what kind of
job it is right if we see a senior in
the title we know it's not gonna be a
junior developer job if we see manager
in the title we know it's not gonna be a
junior developer job another common
thing we might see is like a senior
abbreviated as SR and see it in there
but I know that's it's done so maybe if
we see that word as our dot at all
then we we want to filter it out so this
is our set in Redis so we're gonna want
our filter before that
that's all pages filter can always
factor this a to a function later but
true now
let's um let's do it this way okay
new array jr. jobs it's gonna be fill a
subset of all jobs and we're gonna
filter based on a few different
parameters looking at each job okay
we're gonna use one super important
thing here and that is the string that
includes function and we're gonna use
that on job title so if the job title
includes or rather stop serie okay let's
do it this way actually job title equals
job title to lower case it's important
we can example we saw in the terminal
was in all caps so we want to reduce
that kind of variation by just lower
case in the whole title we also don't
have to keep accessing the object if we
just start in a variable so this is this
is for one job and we're going through
392 so we're gonna have to go through
each one of those jobs real fast that's
part of the reason to why we're doing
this cron method is because if we
fetched the jobs on every front end
request we'd have to do this whole
filter thank every time and it's gonna
be the same logic so in general when
you're doing the same logic for every
client request that's definitely a good
case for caching or even database the
normalization so replicating data in
your store that's a commonly a common
read pattern rather alright we could be
more terse about this but let's just
make it super clear and have a default
case let is do two equals true
then there's gonna be our logic and then
we're gonna just return the result is
jr. okay now this is gonna be our main
algorithm logic here okay so if job
title includes senior we gotta remember
we changed it to lowercase or job title
includes integer or job title includes
sr dot
senior or another one I'm gonna and I
thought about this before I'm gonna put
in his architect because that is
generally a more senior role as well
that you're not going to be able to do
as a junior developer that's something
you have to gain a little skill from
then you can design whole systems and
you may or may not be the one
implementing them as well but here's all
the cases we want to filter out if any
of these are true
is junior equals false okay so this is
the most clear we could way we could do
it but I'm actually going to cut this
part out and then we'll do return false
otherwise we don't actually need else
just if that didn't happen
turn true okay now we could test in our
in our code how many get actually
filtered out by this by console logging
filtered down to turn your jobs and we
do have this one up here
I think yeah we'll leave that in make
sure I think junior jobs in here only
cuts like success okay let's bother you
ok restart oops
restart clean slate
we'll get this extra log we'll see how
much damage our filter does and then we
will still set that in Redis and then we
can make sure it's still in there please
work hey nice pool so if we're filtering
out okay
we went down from 392 all the way to 245
so we're filtering out almost 1/3 of the
jobs just with these words which i think
is already making our app useful to some
degree obviously more complex we make
this algorithm we could search through
the job description look for years of
experience there's definitely more more
titles we can include here but that
would depend like what we see in the
JSON we can kind of pluck words out of
there be like oh yeah this was obviously
a senior term - and then add it to this
list but for now I think it's a good
start ok let's see back in our landing
you just did our filter algorithm or
very basic version node work is done so
this whole section is done Redis is done
API and then we'll we'll finish up with
our front-end and then finally deploy ok
so actually just close everything open
up API index Tijs
just want a super simple Express up
Express
again same thing I said before just do
that NPM install and then from there you
take the most basic example make my port
3001 because I know my front-end is
running a 3000 get a little bit of extra
space here and okay and then this route
we don't need a slash for just need a
route called jobs okay I love this part
Eric's press install went through over
here let's do let's just run a note on
API and XJS sample app listening on port
3001 and then if i curl which is just
sending a request to something on the
port 3000 1/8 the hello world back sweet
okay this is gonna be the simplest API
ever and we just want to use that Redis
library we already installed and we're
gonna use the get which we already
commented out and we already know which
key we're giving yet because we only set
one that really simplifies it so we need
to copy actually all this code and
delete this because we don't need it
here get the Redis Klein get another
instance of that here and then do the
get async and this is where the async
part is really gonna come in handy to
convert this route to an async function
let me do jobs here wait get a sink
just hard code that in now let's
remember we string a fight it so
json.parse and I'm gonna actually undo
this because we are just gonna have to
restring a file when we set it to our
client but um in the meantime just to
see the length and or rather see that
the length matches our our length that
we put in let's parse it and then let's
do not like okay so it's kind of a lot
that we did without testing it restart
our server be the same curl oh man okay
2:45 I don't remember if that's how many
we put in we're definitely getting a
list of 2:45 which is a good sign
let's just try sending this back and see
if we get that full string if I'd object
it's exactly what I want and it's that
easy so that's already done so I don't
know how long it's been guys but with
this simple of an API we can literally
we've literally been able to create all
this like in such a short amount of time
we have a data feed and you can
replicate like before right before I go
further you can replicate this in any
this is like a 90% applications if you
have a data feed we have storage you
have a worker that's doing some async
tasks on an interval
it's called batch processing you have an
API that's called by front-end this is
like 90% of crud applications that's
create read up load delete in this case
we're only really reading from the front
end but the back end is doing some more
complex stuff including an algorithm the
pieces that we're using are used in some
way in almost every large-scale
application so doing this as an MVP is
like a really good exercise
all right let's push on I might be
getting a little bit tired but let's
keep it going
yeah so we have our API running let's
keep this running all right let's just
restart this so we have the log that we
know we're listening and I'm gonna go
back into our client folder okay so
we're back in our app close that we're
back in our app function which we we
mentioned we're gonna put the state in
let's pull this back up so make sure
it's still running all good to call our
API programmatically the same way we're
doing with curl here we just need to
call this URL with a function that we're
gonna make called fetch jobs
all its gonna do is use the browser
version of fetch which we don't need to
import because it's built into browsers
like Chrome let's sum instead of
hard-coding
do a job API URL constant
it'll just be exactly what we have over
here since this is a sync we can use in
a weight a weight Monst jobs
oh wait of course this will be in JSON
so we have to convert it to JSON I just
do that call this Reds all this JSON go
so wait as that JSON and before going
further let's just log that out okay how
do we call this in our client the find
my number used I know I'm getting there
okay have you seen my past videos I
talked about react hooks these are
replacing all react class components now
we just have functional components and
we've seen hooks for use reducer use
state and all that kind of stuff since
this app is just a very simple state
it's a list of jobs I don't feel like I
need to use a reducer and I know that
exactly the shape of these jobs as well
so I don't need to do any reducer like
manipulation and it's also very
hierarchical and shallow application
meaning I just want to pass down these
jobs one level to my jobs view component
from this app state I started talking
about hooks and we've used the use state
hook a lot in my past videos but we're
gonna use one that we haven't used too
much yet here which is called use effect
and that's basically replacing the
component did mount or component did
update function from past versions of
react
so I'm gonna use it here react I use
effect and then this function actually
takes a anonymous function in which I
can do some function calls some async
function calls as well as a second
argument which is the basically hooks
that I want to watch to update but if I
pass in an empty array this reactor use
effect will act exactly like a component
did mount all right inside here just
gonna fetch jobs and I also want to
think about how I'm gonna store those
jobs so let's also do a use state hook
it's never jobs lot so let me just do
job list let's react on use state ok
jobs react I'll use state and then I'll
initialize this to an empty list which
I'm actually gonna pass in here so when
I do that that should actually clear out
all my jobs okay good because I'm
initializing it to an empty list okay in
here I'm fetching jobs console.log JSON
see what happens here fail to fetch
right this is one thing you're good to
definitely run into if you're writing
Express EPS and you're pretty new it's
the access control allow or is it so
this is something you have to set in
your server if you're accessing
endpoints from a different base URL
it's called cross-origin resource
sharing and you basically have to set a
server header in your api that allows
request from the URL that is the origin
so recall that our react apps running on
localhost 3000 as we can see here so all
i have to do is set a header header
I think it's like just literally that
but let me just uh let me just copy
something to so I make sure doing it
right
cores res better Express yeah here it is
that's all I need Brett's header access
control origin but if I do the star that
makes them not protected so I just want
to make this HCP localhost 3000 now this
will I think up 92 percent sure it's
gonna work I type it right
huh I didn't restart my server that's
what I was the 8% me now restarting it
ah nice guys there we go
that's all their jobs beautiful okay
we're getting close
okay fetch jobs is um it's working I
think what we still need is a call back
to to update these jobs so let's just do
this update call back as we know when we
use a used state hook the second
variable that we D structure from the u
s-- state hook is a function in which we
can pass a argument that is the new
value of our state for job list so if I
pass it in here like this
update callback and then I pass the JSON
directly into this I'm actually just
setting the value of jobless to this
JSON which is as we could see over here
and array of size 245 containing our
jobs okay so I got update callback job
list I didn't even have to do anything
else it's already rendering all the jobs
that are from github that's pretty cool
hey guys I'm back with a new shirt let's
finish up this front-end and then get
this app deployed I've pulled up another
plan board here just to make it a little
bit more clear what we want to do with
the front-end like I said before we
always want to have a plan before we
just jump into coding and the first
thing I'm gonna draw out is just the
current way the app looks which is just
the title and then the list of all our
jobs here right now our jobs only have
the title and the company name but we're
definitely going to want also to have
the location so title company
we're definitely gonna want location as
well as the time posted and I think the
best format for time is how long ago so
today one day ago two days ago etc now
this is in the ListView and we had a
think about to what is gonna happen when
we click on a job and in that case I
want to build a detail view modal also
known as a dialog or a pop-up then we'll
show more details about the job which
include the company logo description as
well as the apply link and that could
also be a button if we decide to make it
like that ok so these are the main
things we still need - excuse me these
are the main things we wanted our
front-end
the good news is since we already have
the JSON we just have to pull it out of
the JSON of each job and create a little
bit extra functionality to make this
modal animate luckily this is pretty
easy with material UI and in fact the
main reason I wanted to use it for this
project because you get the modal for
free with all the animations and stuff
like that so let's just jump back over
to our front-end here and I'm gonna pull
open the jobs component here I have very
an h1 but I think this title is
definitely a little bit too big I don't
think it I think that's pretty obvious
and I'm gonna switch this up to still
using a h1 HTML under the hood but the
variant will actually make it an h4
stylistically so that's a pretty cool
trick if you want to maintain the
benefits of having an h1 for SCO and so
on diving
the job itself let's actually log out
what a single job is gonna look like
just so we know what we're working with
and instead of doing that here in the
job component I'm gonna do it in jobs
and we could just look at what the first
job looks like so I'm going to use jobs
0 for that then we'll open the console
and see that we have the fields we can
use here so I said we wanted to add
location and time posted to our list
view we could pretty easily just pull
out location in our job component like
the way we've been doing with the other
ones
and there it goes this is looking a
little bit let's say disorganized but
let's worry about that in just a moment
for now I'm just gonna throw these all
in a div which is gonna be floating to
the left of our box and instead of space
around I want to change this CSS to
space between it'll make sense more in a
minute why I'm doing that
finally in another div let's do the
created date which I believe is over
here in our JSON as well created
underscore at and I'm just kind of using
these typography elements
interchangeably as divs so later on we
can change the size of these different
things
okay so created at let's just see if the
spacing looks all right there now that I
see this here I think the date doesn't
actually look too bad as long as we make
it a little bit shorter so let's just
split it by space and then take the the
first three words so let's take co2 for
and then join that by a space so all I'm
doing here is taking Sunday June I've
out of this longer string I meant to do
Oh two three there we go so we get index
zero one and two all right looking at
our page it deserves a little bit of
padding just it's pushed up against the
side here so let's add that quickly and
then keep going let see your body a
margin top and bottom zero left and
right forty
okay top and bottom 20
alright then within job maybe we give a
little padding top and bottom left right
10 okay pretty good
now inside job will actually add some
hierarchy style hierarchy to our job
title
- h5 h6 on this
and so on we could just keep updating
editing this I think I'm actually gonna
flip these around each 6h 5 but you get
the point you could just keep tweaking
it ok let's add that pagination thing I
mentioned it's gonna be kind of a fake
pagination you're supposed to do it on
the server to not load all your results
at once but this is a good stopgap we
start just with the client
implementation and then later if we want
to improve the performance we could do
the server side too but long story short
we have over 200 results we want these
on more than one page so they're more
navigable so to solve this I open a
material UI page for the stepper
component and I really like this one
down here called the mobile stepper
progress so you could click through it
like this it fills up kind of a progress
bar and it says mobile but I like it so
I'm just gonna pull it over let's see
let's just pull over everything here
just in case we need it and then paste
it right into our jobs component and we
could use the word step here
interchangeably with page and I'm
putting this state in jobs because it's
more of a view state rather than an
actual database state so all our logic
concerning our view is going to actually
be in jobs and not in the app file ok so
since these each have their own function
handle next set oh sorry handle next
handle back just gonna copy these
directly over to paste those right in
function inside a function and all right
finally I'm going to just put this whole
thing below our jobs map and let's see
if by pasting it directly in we
we need to do anything else just gonna
make sure that's formatted correctly
saved it and let's just take this out
classes yeah I don't think Oh the MDOT
direction RTL okay let's see how theme
is being used cuz this is kind of a all
right all right I don't know why that
would change from left to right but it
might be a mobile implementation
specific thing so let's just take this
and hard coat it as right and we'll hard
code this one as left and see if we run
into any problems okay save that and
can't find module oh I forgot about this
material you icons is a separate library
so we have to also install that in our
client darn add material UI i conce
now while that's installing let's think
about how else we want to use our pages
if we want to artificially construct
these pages from a larger list then we
basically just want to break things into
a slice depending on the number of
results we want to show at a given time
so let's think of it as a moving window
of 50 so if step equals 1 or let's say
step equals 0 then we want to show 0
through 49 step equals 1 show 50 through
100 and so on or maybe 50 through 99
okay so since our icons finished let's
see if that worked we got to go all the
way to the bottom and yes it is here
next and back ok ok so let's make this
more dynamic steps is hard-coded as 6 if
we want 50 per page we're gonna have to
do our well since we're gonna use this
in a couple different places let's get
our job length or num jobs equals jobs
that like just for better abstraction
steps will be num jobs divided by 50 and
then we'll math.floor that or let's
actually math.ceil that because it'll be
minimum one page could have you know
only one job on it so we want minimum
okay so that seems about right
it seems like we have about four pages
just by the amount of times I click that
and let's add a little more detail to
right
above this mobile stepper that just says
and I'm just making it a different now
but we could change it page active step
of num jobs okay
not okay let's let's let's factor this
out numpages numpages equals this and
then we can also use this where we are
oh just like in again
um pages like that yeah I'm feeling
pretty confident about that see if it
worked if we go to the bottom my wrist
is getting real tired of scrolling here
right and then one thing I actually
meant to do earlier too is
all the way down okay Oh five-o back 1 2
3 4 5 ok so the display number we want
to actually be active step plus 1
because we're zero index and we're going
up to four yeah so this will this will
work on pages minus one because the
index is actually one less than the true
value one two three four five
okay we'll just leave it as numpages
alright one other thing that i meant to
add earlier is the total number of jobs
at the top right under the title so
let's do a variant h6 and put in the
total number of jobs here num jobs
245 cool getting very close to being
done with the front end here Oh
cancel that okay now let's implement the
actual pagination and we could do that
by just creating a slice that we're
gonna map over instead of the list of
all jobs jobs on page which is just jobs
slice okay let's think about how to do
this
first number is going to be okay yeah so
active step let's keep in mind is our
page that we're on now so the lower
bound is going to be active step times
50 and the upper bound is going to be
active step times 50 plus 50 now all
we're gonna map is job's on page not the
full list
and now we only have 50 so much more
navigable in terms of what's being
rendered and then if we go to the next
page it updates next page updates sweet
all right that is our pagination done
now all we need left is this pop-out
modal and that our front-end will be all
we need left is the pop-out modal and
our front-end will be totally done so
what I want to do is click on this and
then it'll give me a more detailed view
as well as a link where I can apply so
the first thing I want to do is add a
hover state to this job div with a hover
pseudo-class and CSS and then I'll just
make cursor:pointer pointer and I could
also make the colors a gray color just
so it's very clear that we are hovering
over this page or over the the job that
I'm indicating so that that doesn't look
great but it's it's okay for now let's
just make this a little bit of a darker
gray than dark grey all sixes here
all right so that looks fine okay so
there's our hover state now on on-click
we're gonna want to push that job into
the modal State because we want to know
which job specifically to display in the
modal we also want to set a modal open
flag to let the app know to show the
modal itself I think this is gonna make
a lot more sense when I actually read it
out so I'm gonna add it to the mmm let
me think about this yeah I'm just gonna
add it to the bottom of jobs below my
mobile stepper and I'm gonna pull
another component from material UI to do
that and you might have guests it's
gonna be a dialog component so if you go
under feedback there is a dialogs and I
kind of already know the one I want cuz
I there's a lot of them and it's gonna
be the slide in alert
I just think this one looks pretty cool
because you click it then it oh that
didn't slide in where's the slide okay
so you can see there it kind of slid up
and in my computer's going slow but
it'll look cool okay so we have to
import a bunch of these components for
this one to work in a perfect world you
would make this modal its own component
and I think I will do that actually call
it job modal da Jas
let's bring it react export default
function job modal and our prop is gonna
be called job returning JSX and
importing everything I just copied also
there's some forward ref business going
on here but I'll just trust that works
like the material UI Doc's say it does
and let's bring all of this in to yeah
I am gonna delete these though
or rather I'm gonna move these into our
parent component because that's where we
want to manage the state from it's gonna
go in the jobs component
let's consolidate this down
this is for pagination and then modal
consolidate this down to okay now we
want to import job modal
and put this at the top here actually
job modal open is open job is okay now
this is where we have to define our
actual modal state active modal active
now select a job let's do select a job
so let's do just one more state your
state starting out it'll be an empty
object default state and select job will
occur when we click on a job on click
set some more room there select like job
like that so there's a callback in the
on click function that will run when we
click and it's gonna set the selected
job to whatever job we click good start
and then that selected jobs being passed
into job modal let's just rename this to
be extra clear d-structs your job and
open and if there's no job title
we know this hasn't been set yet so we
just return nothing that's just
protecting against a empty object and um
let's see oh yeah we also got a pass in
our up well no we don't need this
because this is happening one level up
right and that also reminds me we have
to not only select the job but set the
modal to open as well
and don't click open
handle close is going to happen here and
all like no and all close
okay
hold that out and okay let's see what
errors were getting I'm sure this isn't
gonna work out of the gate but
just got a typo there
okay so if I click what happens
alright [ __ ]
okay we actually have to pass down this
function like that and then we open job
and we do that on click here because it
wasn't running so we need to we needed
to put it on the on the child oh nice
nice got it down all right
so title now we could start putting in
our our variables this job title instead
of just having that there maybe we also
put the logo of the company so yeah
let's make this fancy let's do a image
source company job company logo and
you tell logo in here we will do detail
logo make it pretty small 30 pixels low
right now back over here we have
correspond the company and in the
content we definitely want the
description okay one tricky thing though
you'll notice that the description is in
HTML it's an HTML string so a trick with
react is um if you want to actually
render HTML from a string it's
considered dangerous because you can put
in script tags and execute script on
someone else's browser so if you want to
allow this as the developer you have to
use the dangerously set HTM inner HTML
attribute like that and then you pass in
an object with the key HTML equals
whatever you want your HTML string to be
and that'll do the trick but it's um
again dangerous so use it sparingly as
for the buttons at the bottom let's
change this one to apply and this will
just be a link to the original job
posting for now so we'll wrap this in an
anchor tag a href wrap it an anchor tag
of job URL which is the link to the
original job you see here closing anchor
tag goes on the base side of the button
maybe we don't actually want this button
to close a modal and then I'm just gonna
save everything we just did now I'm
opening it again we do have an error but
it's looking pretty good and I'm
wondering if the the reason for this is
that I just have to use the dangerously
set innerhtml directly on this see if
that works
changing this to a self closing tag
one thing I want to do also has put a
break between the the title here and the
company because they were both on the
same line actually let's just do it like
this put in a little - to separate them
what I open click ok awesome and if I
click apply it'll take me to the company
or rather the original job posting which
we may want to make a little more
complicated down the road but for now
it's good one more thing I want to do is
make this link a target link so it'll
open in a new tab underscore link so
that'll open this link in a new tab
all right as far as the modal goes I
think we're pretty we're pretty much
good so for now I mean that could be
obviously we could add a little more
pizzazz to this front-end if we you know
continue improving it over time but for
now I mean it's very functional it does
everything we wanted to do I can click
on different jobs and get get a
different you know listing this opens
and closes and these are all working
with the logo and I could scroll it
looks pretty good it looks pretty good
so I want to say our front end is done
all right guys we're so close to being
done we literally just have to deploy
our app and we'll be home free
a lot of people are afraid of deployment
but it's not that bad if you break it
down into steps when I think about what
we need it's gonna be a domain pointing
to a virtual private server which is
hosting nginx now nginx is called a
reverse proxy it connects your server to
the public internet and provides like
protection between those requests the
other thing we're going to need is a
process manager on our server after we
install our dependencies that we have in
our local environment so we're going to
need the same things
Redis we're gonna need nodejs and then
we're just going to need to send over
all our files so they can actually run
on our server in the same way they're
running locally so let's do it I've
pulled up a bunch of Docs here we're
gonna need it's just gonna be a lot of
copy and pasting for server
configurations and I'll put all these
links in the description so like I
mentioned first we need a domain I
already bought one on Google domains but
you can buy a domain a ton of different
places I just like Google because the
interface and it's because where my
other domains are so I've opened my
domain I already bought it
normal com domain is going to be about
fourteen dollars a year and the first
thing we need to do is use the
digitalocean name servers so that domain
can be directed over to our server so
you'll see that I have clicked on my
domain I've open the DNS tab and then
there's a name servers tab and I've
clicked used custom name servers now I'm
gonna put that on pause and jump over to
the digital ocean dashboard you can make
a digital ocean account for free and
it'll give you this dashboard where you
could create projects which have
resources inside of them a project is
basically just a folder for a bunch of
resources including domains and virtual
servers and then all this stuff you see
down here so I'm just going to create a
new project and call it a entry level
software jobs II lsj and it's a web
application so I'm just gonna create
that and then like I said it's just a
folder we're gonna start with no
resources so I'm gonna skip that step
for now but right away we're going to
create a domain and the domain is going
to be the one that we bought entry level
software jobs calm so I'm just gonna put
that here and then add it and you'll see
that I have the digitalocean name
servers here so it's NS one two and
three so I'm just going to copy this by
clicking it and enter it here and we
need all three of them so I'm just gonna
expand this out make this one two and
then make this one three
now when you change the nameservers it
could take a little while to actually
update it says up to 24 hours a lot of
time for me it's instant but it's not
always the case so you might have to
wait and we'll see what happens here
so next I'm gonna do is actually create
a droplet which is our VPS virtual
private server you could do this on any
cloud provider other common ones are AWS
or Google cloud but on AWS this is
called an ec2 and then I'm not sure what
it's called out in Google cloud maybe
just a VPS but on do it's called a
droplet which is just a server so what
you have to do is choose your operating
system I'm choosing Ubuntu Linux 1804
and you can choose the size of your
server you could always upgrade it later
which requires a server restart so I'm
just gonna pick the $15 a month which
has three gigabytes of RAM and 60
gigabyte of storage and then moving down
you could choose your data center
where's your server physically located
and then moving down you can do private
networking is useful if you have you
know multiple servers talking to each
other but the most important part is
here add your SSH keys you're probably
going to want to do a new SSH key but I
already have mine saved here you
definitely need this step because you
need it to actually get into your server
to connect to it otherwise there's no
way to get into it so you definitely
need a SSH key and then feel free to
look up its tutorial to set that up I'm
not going to do it here but it's pretty
easy to do and then I'm just gonna call
a hostname master because we're only
gonna have one server with all our
services and then finally create this so
this server is now being created it
doesn't take too long and I'm gonna go
back into my domain and add an a record
for at which is just the root domain and
I want it to direct to our master server
so I'm just going to create that record
and that is step one in linking our
domain to our server
now once this finishes which it looks
like it just
did we got the green light here I'm
gonna copy the ipv4 address that's the
IP address and I'm just going to ssh
directly into this server by doing route
at IP address just like that ssh route
at IP address and it looks like it
wasn't completely finished loading so
i'm just going to try it one more time
and now we type in yes and there we go
so you can see our operating system here
and now we have a command line in our
server so we're actually in our server
through a secure shell that's ssh so i'm
just gonna clear the sabbath command k
and it's important to look at the
command prompt to know where we actually
are we don't want to be installing
things on our local machine that we
think we're doing on our server so
always keep an eye on this I'm rude at
master master being the name of our
server alright so as I mentioned we have
to install nginx to actually talk to the
public Internet and if we have a domain
we also want to install an SSL
certificate which gives us the HTTPS
secure connection and that sounds
complicated but it's really easy if you
use the tool like cert bot I have the
documentation open here all you do is
you choose your software on your system
and as you'll recall we used 1804 and
it'll give you a series of commands to
just enter into your server and it'll
install pretty much everything you need
so I'm just gonna run these commands and
a few of them require me to hit yes so
I'm just gonna do them one at a time
make sure each one works while
periodically clearing out my console
with command K just to give us more
space so there's one where I have to hit
yes and let's just keep going through
these
so the nice thing about this cert bot is
usually you have to install nginx on its
own but this will install our nginx and
our certificate our certificate all at
the same time and then we just have to
update our nginx config and we'll be
already serving our application to the
to the public Internet through our
domain okay
last command here yes
alright okay I'm gonna
see this pseudo sir bought nginx command
which is what actually runs the
installation and then I'm going to enter
that in and it'll take us through a
series of prompts to actually install
this so I'm gonna put an email and then
agree No
now we need our actual domain got to
make sure we smell it right here
entry level software jobs com
an important thing to take note of here
is where it deployed our certificate so
it deployed our certificate in sights
enabled slash default which is a config
file that we later have to edit if we
want to make any changes to our domain
configuration so we're gonna open that
later to update the config but just keep
in mind that location okay
congratulations it was successful so
let's test that and see if our name
servers have propagated yet by going to
the domain and that's exactly what we
want to see you
welcome to nginx so this is a non
configure nginx but it is running and
we're connected to our server from the
public Internet so that's great so we're
done with sir bot and then like I
mentioned we want to next edit our
configuration file which is at that
location et Cie and genetics sites
available default and I'm gonna open
this with the vim text editor by typing
in VI and then the file location now vim
is pretty cool if you haven't used it
but it's basically installed on all UNIX
operating systems that is Linux and Mac
OS and it gives us a text editor right
in the console so what I'm doing here is
I'm scrolling down to the second server
block which is actually indicated by
this server bracket notation and I'm
gonna look in here and I can see my URL
is defined here and being forwarded to
basically port 80 so um within this
location block I'm just gonna completely
delete what's in here that is inside the
location block and then I'm going to put
a new config in that is just pretty much
something you have to copy and paste to
do port forwarding to a local port on
your machine so I'm gonna copy this
location here and I will put this link
in the description where I'm getting
this from but this is just a standard
configuration for port forwarding so I'm
just gonna paste it right in we have
that and then the other thing we need is
to put this outside of our server block
which is actually the port that we're
forwarding to port 80 sorry I messed
that one up actually
undo go in to make a little space and
then I'm gonna paste that in there so
we're forwarding localhost 5,000 to port
80 that's what this upstream is doing so
I'm gonna save this with colon escape :
WQ and that saves the file and then I'm
gonna do pseudonyms sudo system control
restart nginx and that just restarts or
nginx no errors okay so that's pretty
good now let's keep moving and install
our dependencies on our machine so I'm
going over to this other tutorial how to
setup nodejs on ubuntu link in
description and i have to install
actually the nodejs version that we need
which is at least 6 to run create react
app build so I'm changing directory you
know the home directory that's the
squiggly line and I'm curling this file
now I'm just running the script that I
received from this file curl making a
request to download some dot s H file
which includes basically some setup
configuration for installing nodejs
clearing the terminal and then actually
installing nodejs through apt-get which
is a linux equivalent of homebrew that's
for installing just pretty much any
software ok that worked and now I want
to install this build essential file
which is or rather module which is a
helps us run certain NPM packages so I
just make sure we have compatibility
with every NPM package that we want to
use ok next let's actually test out that
our port forwarding is working by
creating a test file called hello Jas so
I'm going to do that with them here
hello Jas and then insert this code and
I just want to actually change that to
5000 which is what we set up our port
forwarding to as you might recall and
then I'm just going to save that with
escaped WQ and then run it with node so
node hello Jas and it's running
so let's see if that is actually being
forwarded correctly and it is so that's
great
okay just scrolling down this page and
I'm gonna stop that server the next
thing we need to do is install p.m. to
our process manager which allows us to
run out all our services our API
front-end and worker at the same time
without us being actively on the server
so it'll run them restart them capture
logs and do a lot of stuff that's pretty
cool for actually managing our server
processes so I'm just gonna do oh no we
don't have MPM installed so of course um
you know no tutorials perfect so it's
just install NPM as well it normally
does that when I install node but I
guess I'm using a different set of
commands this time to do this so
hopefully this just um doesn't give us
any problems later and let's see if that
worked okay sweet so let's do that and
the same command as before NPM install
GPM - oops okay and then to run our
react app we all we need to NPM install
G another dependency called serve okay
so we got those two done and let's just
test PM 2 with our hello J s file so
let's do p.m. to start L out J s and
we'll see our p.m. to daemon is spawned
so now we can see our p.m. to processes
with p.m. - PS and there's a status CPU
and memory which is pretty cool that we
get those stats and a dashboard and then
if i refresh my page the app is still
running in the background so that's
great so if you remember the steps we
outline at the beginning the next thing
we need to do is actually get our files
on to this server and once we do that we
should be pretty much done so I'm gonna
open up a second command window here and
this is um you'll see in the command
prompt my local machine so what we want
to do is send through the files that we
made in local development before we do
that I'm going to open up this
a set of files and make one critical
change that will allow us to access our
API on our local server and that is to
basically change this to just a relative
path so I'm changing this to just slash
jobs and actually I want to change it to
be a little more clear to be slash API
slash jobs now that means we also have
to change our API route which shouldn't
be a problem
slash API slash jobs and we have to make
one change in our package JSON and
that's adding a proxy config which
allows this to still work on local
development this doesn't affect anything
on production so proxying all api routes
to a target of local host sorry new the
double quotes there HDTV local host 3001
was our API server I believe and I'll
save that and again that just helps us
you know still develop in the same way
but we need to make one config change
for the production server as well so
that was our change in in our files
and as I mentioned I'm gonna go actually
back into that nginx config file etc'
nginx sites available default and I have
to add one additional location block
just for the API route because basically
what this is doing is appending the
relative path to the end of our URL and
nginx needs to know to direct this to
actually port 3001 on when it's being
run by the browser so it's just
basically a different port forwarding
for a different path and the way we do
that is by getting a proxy pass to HTTP
localhost 3001 semicolon is important i
forget that a lot so escape wq2 save and
then system control restart nginx
alright so we're about to send through
our files to our production server i'm
going to change into my client and then
i'm going to do an NPM run build to
create a production build of my react
app that we
we just built this includes everything
from our package.json and also our a
minified version of our javascript files
and our bundle j/s now we can see that
we have a build folder and we send this
through the same way that we actually
SSH in with a command called SCP and
then I'm gonna put in an R flag for
recursive so it'll send anything
recursively within the build folder to
our server URL I'm just gonna copy that
again from here by going to master oops
that's not good okay no it hasn't been
destroyed false alarm
copy the ipv4 and then do the same
syntax root at our IP V address and then
I need to put in a colon and then the
home directory so where are we sending
it to on our server and we just want to
make sure it's going to the home
directory okay so that's sent through
all our files from the build folder and
now when i LS inside of our server
you'll see the build folder is there so
that's great so let's start this up
we're not gonna have any data running
yet because we don't have our worker
started on our server but let's start
this up by p.m. to stop hello this was
our test server we know it works and
then we'll do p.m. to delete hello and
now I'm gonna do a special kind of
syntax to actually serve our build
folder publicly and that's going to
combine the serve package we downloaded
with the PM to process manager so I'm
gonna do p.m. to start serve - - s built
this is just saying use the serve
package and run this command - s build
under serve it's the same as PM to
starting just running this command serve
s build and in fact let's try this first
serve s build to see if our application
is going to be served so it's a serving
local and network to the port
we're forwarding to and there it is
already we could see it's kind of
working
here's our domain and then here's our
front end with no data but um like I
just typed we're gonna run this in p.m.
to with p.m. to start serve as build and
you'll see it created under a name serve
that's probably not the best but um we
can keep that in mind this is running
under the process serve and it's online
and then when I free fresh it's still
running so that's cool now we have our
front-end running so we have to send
through our worker and our API files so
I'm gonna clear that out this is our
local machine again change directory add
to our home directory and then we want
to send through SCP are let's see API
and I'm just going to hit up a few times
to get this command back send through
the API folder to our home directory
then I'll send through the Worker folder
then I'll also send through package JSON
to get our dependencies namely Express
and the Redis client so back over in our
VPS I'm you going to need to install
Redis so I'm just going to do sudo
apt-get install Redis yes and we can
test whether that installed by doing
Redis CLI as we did on local and it
seems to work so exit and now that we
have all our files here let's just check
that we do let's do NPM install to get
those dependencies and now let's start
our worker or rather let's start our API
VM to you start API index Jas I'll do -
- name API and then we'll also start our
worker p.m. to start worker index Jas
name worker okay
and
things seems to be running but how are
we sure that our work is working well
let's do p.m. two logs worker just to
see if those logs that we set with the
console logs that actually give us the
indication workers working are actually
going to run so you'll remember that we
did a cron for every minute so let's see
if those logs are actually gonna run
after a minute so we just got to wait
and see if that happens and then once
that happens our register will be loaded
so in theory we should be able to
refresh our page and then see all the
jobs there but right now we just got to
wait this dispenses is kind of killing
me here I feel like it's been longer
than a minute I don't know if it's gonna
work or not but I actually have faith
okay there we go
come on worker you can do it okay it's a
success okay and so now our Redis should
be full if i refresh there's all our
jobs amazing so we have a deployed
application everything looks just as I
did on local if I click into these jobs
let's see it works there's our
description logo and everything and then
if I click apply it'll take us to that
position so that's pretty cool guys we
just deployed our whole app and it
didn't even take that long I feel like
that was around 30 minutes or so alright
guys that's it we basically built a
whole production application in less
than 100 minutes and we got it deployed
and now it's running on the public
internet at entry-level software jobs
comm so go check it out but um I'm
thinking next there's a few critical
things we have to do before we're ready
for like a full production launch so to
speak this was just our base framework
that we're building more features off of
but at minimum I think we need a few
more data feeds and we need to make our
algorithm a lot more robust prevent it
from breaking on errors as well as
filtering down those jobs a lot more
because if we get in five feeds we're
just gonna have a huge amount of jobs
and we really want to make sure those
are entry level jobs so I'm thinking
that we parse through the description
and look for like three to five years of
experience and take
those out I think anything less than
three years would qualify as an
entry-level job so again we're gonna
have to keep working on the algorithm
and then otherwise we're gonna want to
add a little bit of monitoring logging
different things like that but that can
all come later our MVPs done and our
base of our application is done so
that's pretty cool so anyway hope you
learn something let me know if you have
any questions and I will talk to you
guys soon